one of Alec Murdoch's former friends
takes the stand again this time in front
of a jury he described the night
Murdoch's wife and son were killed
his neck and cry didn't know what to say
hug his neck and cry yes sir
lawn crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everybody to Long crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber Alec Murdoch's murder
trials winding down for the day in South
Carolina as the state brings in more
witnesses to shore up its case jurors
and spectators at the Murdoch trial
likely noticed a very heavier police
presence at the courthouse on Thursday
after a bomb threat interrupted court
for several hours the day before now
long crime daily told you on Wednesday
that judge Clifton Newman stopped Court
proceedings around lunchtime saying that
everyone needed to leave the building an
anonymous caller said that there was a
bomb in the judge's Chambers law
enforcement checked the entire building
and said that it was all a hoax members
of the bomb squad patrolled around the
courthouse Thursday just to make sure
now much of the testimony inside of the
courtroom on Thursday centered around
Chris Wilson Chris Wilson is Murdoch's
former best friend a fellow attorney he
had testified last Thursday but this
time the jury heard what he had to say
Wilson's testimony included information
about Murdoch's alleged Financial
misconduct or at least what he knew
about it he says that Murdoch told him
after the murders that he had stolen
money and had been addicted to opioid
for years the prosecution has argued
that Alec Murdoch killed his wife Maggie
and Son Paul to distract from or
possibly prevent information about his
alleged fraud from coming to light a
sometimes emotional Wilson told the
court how he found out that Maggie and
Paul were dead
I was asleep
um
my phone's always kind of beside the bed
I could hear it buzzing but I really
wasn't paying any attention
my wife comes in kind of his you know
just hysterical
um
she says you got to wake up you gotta
wake up
I got in the car I went straight to
Moe's grabbed some clothes and went
straight to myself
from Columbia about an hour and 40
minutes or so was it a Defender there
he was yes sir yeah
you talk to him I did I walked in
[Music]
hugged his neck and cried didn't know
what to say hug his neck and cry yes sir
all right here with Terry Austin Brian
buckmeyer Terry it is unusual to have a
bomb threat during the course of a trial
what do you make of that well it is
unusual but this is a very unusual trial
I mean on the one hand it could be
totally unrelated to the case it could
just be someone who is thinking well you
know I want to be involved somehow in
this very big important case but if you
are a conspiracy theorist which I am not
you might think that Alex Murdoch was
behind this somehow trying to stall the
trial or even making people think that
someone is after him so I really hope
the FBI comes in and looks at where that
call came from because if we ever find
out who made that call and if it is
connected to the case I think it'll be
enlightening to say the least there's
not enough weird Theory surrounding Alec
Murdoch Brian you we used can agree that
the prosecution they're making some
strong points but my understanding is
you and one of the producers that we
have here on Long crime daily you're
having some trouble with the timeline
right yeah absolutely Jesse I would
recommend to all of your viewers go to
lawncrime.com check out the Alec Murdoch
double murder day 12 recap and you're
looking at the Timeline right here okay
so you've got when the SUV turns on and
off the SUV is put into park at 9 22 and
then leaves about 21 minutes afterwards
that's presumably the time that Alec
Murdock is at his mother's home then the
vehicle comes back at around 10 o'clock
just before that text to Maggie saying
call me that's when the car was put into
park and we know that he calls at 1006.
when you look at the Timeline he has
about 10 minutes for a kill to clean up
and he has to put away all these clothes
all this stuff it almost seems
impossible for him to do it especially
when we don't have these clothes we
don't have the murder weapon I'm
wondering how the prosecutor's going to
put that together that's something the
defense has highlighted as well and just
to continue with this so during long
crimes lunchtime q a on Thursday
attorney Joe McCullough joined
correspondent Gigi McKelvey outside the
courthouse McCullough is representing
one of the victims in the boat accident
case which about Paul Murdoch and he
talked about what the prosecution is
facing when it comes to convincing a
jury that Murdoch is a murderer
since the burden of proof is on the
state to to present the evidence of the
crime to the jury they raise this issue
but they left out the part about sled
failing to search his home the night of
the murders
he had consented to a search of the home
and and all we've heard in the testimony
is that they went to his bedroom with
him and asked him to remove his clothing
the clothing he had on the at the time
which was a white T-shirt shorts and
whatever kind of shoes to my knowledge
the other clothing has never been
accounted for but that's a curiosity
it's a a fact Omission that will be
troubling to the jury but is that a
reasonable doubt or is it some inference
to be drawn from that and again I think
that it sled uh
curiously did not search the residents
of the only person at the scene of the
crime who armed with a shotgun waiting
for the police to come and he said to
the police that he went back to the
house got a shotgun because he was
scared
so I mean these are things the
prosecution has to deal with in the
jury's mind
all right raising some interesting
points there long crime is covering this
trial for you gavel to gavel you can go
to longcrime.com to see the latest
articles live streams and of course
expert Insight
[Music]
the man accused of killing his wife and
then Googling how to dismember her body
appeared in a Massachusetts court
Thursday morning via Zoom for a status
hearing and during the hearing the
attorney for Brian Wall said that her
team has gotten quote basically nothing
from the prosecution in terms of
Discovery the assistant district
attorney says a grand jury is reviewing
the case and he hopes to have an
indictment in March Anna Walsh was last
seen on New Year's Day she was supposed
to fly to D.C for work but never showed
her company actually reported her
missing and when police spoke to Brian
they say he just couldn't keep his story
straight during his arraignment on
murder charges the prosecutors revealed
some of his search history after his
wife wife went missing including how to
dismember a body while she was behind
bars listened in as it turns attorney
addressed Discovery issues with the
judge
I will say we have received very little
Discovery to date so I'm hoping that the
discovery will be Folsom we've received
like basically nothing
um I have no problem with putting it on
for a month but um and I hope uh in fact
even sooner because if in fact we get
all the discovery that's one thing but
if there's still Discovery issues like
we haven't even received the search
warrants um for my client's car the
inventories for search warrants I mean
the basic stuff that we should have had
um like immediately we don't have so I'm
a little bit skeptical that this uh that
the discovery is going to be Folsom or
that's going to contain everything I
need so if we could have a date like
three weeks out I would for another
status conference just so I can review
the discovery see what is missing if
anything hopefully not
all right Terry so the defense they're
complaining the prosecution hasn't
turned over Discovery but what exactly
is the prosecution required to turn over
almost everything Jesse the prosecution
really from the arrest has to begin
producing documents to the defense team
and those documents can be anything from
obviously a witness list but if they
have a police report and any sort of
documents any sort of computer printouts
that they may have so they have to give
over everything to the defense
especially exculpatory evidence which is
evidence that shows that the defendant
might be guilty it'll help the defendant
in his case you might be innocent might
be innocent that's right it's gulpatory
evidence yes that he might be innocent
thank you Jesse and so he has to give
that over to the defense team but here
it seems like nothing has been turned
over and if that's the case there could
be sanctions now the defense team also
has to turn over the witness list but
not much else Brian why wouldn't the
prosecution do it it seems pretty simple
and straightforward what do you think
they're doing here it could be any
number of things first Terry's right
that's what has to to be turned over but
the devil's in the details it's a matter
of when it has to be turned over for a
lot of cases prosecutors don't need to
turn over the bulk or all of the
discovery until before trial which could
be months or even a year or plus from
now the other thing is maybe they're
still continuing their investigation
we've already heard that the grand jury
has not heard this case in its entirety
as yet so they might just be looking to
turn over Discovery when all is done the
investigation the grand jury
presentation and everything turned over
or it could just be that their
backlogged that they're sloppy they
don't have their act together because
something as simple as a warrant that
they already have that can be emailed
that can be turned over but it's
definitely raising some eyebrows as to
why it hasn't is yet lawyers are people
too we all make mistakes you know it
could be the best of us